vice president Kamala Harris is in
Nevada tomorrow she'll be in Reno Reno
to talk about protecting abortion rights
the event will include appearances from
Reno's mayor and actress Rosario Dawson
vice president Harris last visited Las
Vegas back in August of 2022. over the
weekend vice president Harris was also
here at this abortion rights rally in
Los Angeles Friday the Supreme Court
temporarily preserved access to the drug
after an emergency appeal by the Biden
Administration justices are considering
whether to intervene in this court
battle recently a Texas Federal appeals
court judge ruled to block access to the
abortion drug several GOP lawmakers
though are now challenging their party's
own hard-line abortion position